okay now by the way just to help with
the accuracy of the shape I tend to draw
the asymptotes first because that way
you know your curvature will bend toward
the asymptotes which is which tends to
be what I'm what people get wrong so
that's a big wavy but it won't matter
because the part I'm interested in is
this side anyway so okay so there's a
standard hyperbola they name a point P
and then they have a point P joining
sorry a line P line joining P to the
focus that's parallel to an asymptote
okay so that was a lot of words right so
let's let's try and put a place on this
so for example if I put P here so
they've called this they've given us the
general chord it's a sec theta B tan
theta okay so I'm going to point down
there and then they've got the point the
line rather joining that to the focus
now the focus is going to be on this
side of the hypo and the other focus
will be here the focus if you remember
is what the hyperbola or the problem
whatever it bends around its curvatures
around so apparently that line joining
the that point to our focus is parallel
to one of the asymptotes so I'm going to
draw it in sort of like this okay
all right so there is there is the focus
there what are the quality of the focus
by the way I think they're a zero okay
okay so we've got that let's get going
this is just a standard hyperbola x
squared on a squared minus y squared on
B squared is equal to one now there's
this line joining P to the focus and
it's parallel to and asymptotes so I'll
just stick some arrows on there show
that the asymptotes the directrix and
the tangent at P are concurrent well
okay so three different things right so
there's there's another tangent here or
there we go so deserve is a tangent at P
this is the tangent at P and they're
saying that this tangent that asymptotes
and the directrix which I suppose would
go through here
okay that's the directrix okay
they're suggesting that they all pass
through the one point there that's what
it means that they're concurrent okay is
in room so um being that that's the
point of intersection we're looking for
I'm just going to call that I for
intersection okay so how do I go about
starting this in some ways this is
really just showing that a bunch of
equations are going to set us a bunch of
coordinates are going to satisfy a bunch
of different equations because that's
what will give you concurrence okay so I
need to work out what all of these
pieces are so I think my starting point
is actually going to be SP that line
there I need to know what its equation
is because then I can work out all the
other pieces that relate because in some
ways that line is what's important okay
because they define that as parallel to
the astrodome okay so I'm thinking about
line SP right now okay now I know it
goes through the focus right so I've got
two coordinates and I also know it's
parallel to the asymptotes now I've
drawn two asymptotes the
equations for each of the asymptotes are
plus or minus B on a x-ray they pass
through the origin okay so being that
this one is the positive one it's
equation must be B over a times X that
means it's gradient has to be just be
your ring so therefore I can use point
gradient form to get the to express the
equation of SP okay so Y minus y1 well
it passes through the focus so I'll go Y
minus 0 equals we just established that
the gradient was B over a and then I've
got X minus a a inside the brackets
because that's what my x-coordinate is
okay now if I solve this together with
the equation of the hyperbola which is
which is over here okay then that should
give me the coordinates of P because
that's that's where they two intersect
okay now um so I'll just tighten that up
a little bit that's don't need that zero
I suppose okay so let's go ahead and try
to solve it this is the equation by the
way x squared on a squared minus y
squared on B squared equals one so I
already have Y as a subject here so I -
or just somebody okay
so I'll get x squared on a squared -
okay here's my Y squared so it's B
squared on a squared X minus a or
squared that's my numerator that's Y
squared okay and that's all over B
squared that's
okay what could I do in this well it's
kind of nice that those V Squared's
cancel I've got x squared on a squared
hanging out the front right but then
I've also got um you can see actually
you can multiply through by a squared
coño okay because um I've got a 1 over a
squared there X minus a a or squared
okay so we keep going on and even up
into the shop or not so we're just just
down a little bit okay can we solve it
one day I suggest multiply through by a
squared so that will give me x squared
minus X minus AE or square is equal to a
squared okay let's expand x squared
minus x squared minus 2a X plus a
squared a squared a squared okay so
expand this brackets just be careful for
that negative so x squared minus x
squared plus 2 AE X minus a squared a
squared equals a squared cancel cancel
and what am i after I'm solving these
two simultaneously so I just want the x
coordinate don't know okay so I'll just
rearrange a little bit I'll kick over
that a squared e squared to this side a
squared plus a squared e squared and
then I guess I'm going to divide by 2a E
which gives me factorize that e squared
1 plus e squared there there's a 2a e
there one of the A's will cancel here so
I get a outside of one plus d squared
all over 2 e ok so what have I got I've
got the x-coordinate of this point here
okay now it doesn't take too much work
you can go ahead and do the algebra I
think you guys will be fine
if that's the x-coordinate if you sub
back into our equation here you get a
y-coordinate as well and you should end
up with if you do your numbers right
because I worked this out earlier be
outside of one minus e square on to eat
okay so now this gives me the
coordinates of P now the reason why I
need the coordinates of P is because
that'll give me that will allow me to
work out what the equation of this
tangent is so what's the equation of a
tangent to the hyperbola being that it's
this kind of hyperbola just in general
form okay what's the equation of the
tangent we actually learn a stand and
fall for this right so the tangent will
have an equation in the form x x-1 on a
squared y y1 on b squared and that's
equal to 1 okay so now I can go ahead
and I can actually stick in these points
and I'll guess let's see here well
there's an a there and a be there and
they'll cancel with an A and a B there
so I think you're going to get X outside
of one plus e squared on to a because
you'll have one of the A's left and
you'll get the same thing here except
with the equivalent terms for y now all
of this like this is mostly just algebra
right now but there you go there's the
equation of the tangent it looks a bit
messy we could probably make it a bit
neater but it it's fine all I know is
that all I need is that that's the
actual equation okay all right now let's
just come back here now I've got the
equation the tangent now okay if I can
show that the tangent goes through where
the asymptotes and the directrix
intersect then I'm done
then I'm done okay so all i need's know
is well ok where does the asymptote
intersect with the directrix okay we
left this off before now is the equation
the asymptotes what's the equation of
the directrix if that's a
it should be x equals to a / e right
because we're on the right hand side
okay so it's really easy to work out
where the directrix and the the
asymptote intersects because they're
just straight lines right so I should
have let's see if x equals a over e and
y equals B on a X then Y is equal to B
over a times a over E which is B every
that's the y coordinate you can stick
that back in and you'll get X being a /
e that's that's quite easy to determine
okay so that gives us that's a that's
why I'm calling
I called it I capital I earlier that's
the point where the tangent sorry the
asymptotes and the directrix intersect
okay okay so that's the corner 2 pi
where directrix and asymptotes intersect
so now what I need to do is I need to
put this these coordinates into the
equation that I had for the tangent
which looked like this which I know I
know it's awful but actually the
symmetry of it will work in our
advantage so maybe if I put that this
and we can see it any new piece of paper
okay here we go so I'm going to take x
equals a over E and y equals B over E
and just gonna be careful because you're
not going to sub it into this equation
because then you've got left hand side
and right hand side both there I want to
prove that the left hand side will be
equal to the right hand side if I take
these values so I'll literally say left
hand side that's going to be well X is a
over a times 1 plus E squared all
divided by 2a minus B over E is my Y
value 1 minus e squared all over 2 B II
okay what's this equal to a cancels here
B cancels there that is going to come
onto the denominator isn't it so in both
cases so I've got 1 plus e squared on to
e squared and then I've got 1 minus e
squared on to e squared you can see
what's happening can't you come that's
going to be 1 plus V squared minus 1
plus e squared because I'm just watch
out for that double negative that's all
over 2 e squared so you get 2 e squared
all over 2 e squared which is 1 which is
the right hand side that I wanted so
therefore those coordinates I that
satisfies the equation of the tangent so
that means it's on the taejun
and don't forget that this is where the
this is where the asymptotes and the
directories were intersecting in the
first place so that means they all pass
through the one spot so they're from
current that's